I want to call your blowback I want to
connect this idea to something that we
did last term we don't air one and am
too if you call do you remember what
they were about what was in everyone
what was it a.m. to think big what kind
of stuff do we do and we had lots of um
factorizing expanding you had some
equations to solve to remember that so I
would call that algebraic expressions
that's like 3x plus 5 that's an
algebraic expression right you had to
simplify them you had to work with them
but as well as that you had equations
which is where you have an equal sign
it's not just 3x plus 5 hanging out
there the middle of nowhere it's 3x plus
5 is equal to softly and since its equal
that's why we fought the equation right
that was right at the beginning of the
year and then we kind of respect to time
finance and then we looked at this we
had to draw some graphs to report am too
is about very good so we took those
linear equations like that 3x plus 5
they talked about and we said hey you
can graph these out that shows there's
actually a relationship between two
things right it's like look I've got a
vertical axis I've got a horizontal axis
and then I want to think about how those
two relate to each other do you remember
that this is actually think what I want
you to all have some errands going off
you whenever we looked at a linear
relationships there was always something
or the vehicle access something old
horizontal comparing the two right and
that's why they were related to each
other can anyone think of any examples
at all origin they got some examples of
some of the cares of quantities that we
looked at you would reform i'll start
you off just to get you your head going
we had a look at books like pretty books
any one of the first examples we did was
a company trying to QuickBooks versus
the cost right like production costs
okay to your bed without dare ring a
bell you remember the graph ok hit some
way to help me out we get some a couple
of more easy
yeah so I said yes anything okay so we
talked about our taxi fares what did we
compare it to like the amount you pay
versus what versus the words it's kind
of tricky isn't it for taxis it's
actually a bit of time and a bit of
distance but I think just to simplify it
I think we thought about distance like
the further you drive generally speaking
the more you get charged say yeah well
it's actually a bit of both because
taxis unfortunately a lil bit
complicated in that if you're sitting in
traffic doing nothing there's still
charging you because their engines
running but at the same time if you're
driving for half an hour versus City
your traffic for half an hour they will
also charge me different so it's
actually more things to compare there
but we did look at a very simple graph
of that can someone give you a lot yeah
for a plumber okay so we talked about
like any kind of service fee right and
we talked about like Cola and that kind
of you so the service fee vs now this
time i think it was definitely time like
the walk and the plumber is there the
more they're going to charge you right
ok so that's enough examples all that
was just to demonstrate we don't even
pair of things that they related to each
other and they're changing your
relationship to each other what you're
really talking about is a rate okay
that's that's what we're looking here
today it's like cost per books or
dollars per kilometer or dollars per
hour right so you're always comparing
these two things are you get a rate at
the other side so i might say um dollar
actually all these money dollar per book
sorry dollar per kilometer dollar hour
okay so we have this language of rates
this is called a very very familiar with
but all that means is maybe I want to
put this in a box oh wait is a
comparison between two quantities that
change right such as of the matter buddy
had to spend any better time for the
club is at your house right so that's
already is a compare
in between to changing quantities and
that's why I bet she now have the
measurement because well we're let me
venture stuff you get quantities at the
other end okay so all you have to do to
state the quantity is to have well
what's what amount that's changing over
the other okay so for instance one that
isn't mentioned here is something like
say a speed we know we understand what
speed is and that's kind of what your
classic right how would you write down
the speed of a car what units are we
talking about km/h right so kilometers
is a distance quantity but changes and
ours is a it's a time unit that changes
right and we looked at all of these
units in like our first lesson on this
okay so the first thing you need to be
able to say is just like well can I come
up with a number if for instance let's
just write the example stuff
specifically for example writing this
pair of numbers for we suppose I went
from Sydney to Melbourne which i think
is like 350 miles and suppose it took me
four and a half hours for da baus don't
be a bad drive
what's my speed what's the rate of my
travel from one city to the other well
because i think in clubs per hour i
literally going to take the number of
kilometers and i'm going to divide by
the number of hours so i'm going to say
i'm so gonna run a smooth militar the
speed that's the that's the name of this
ring right the speed is going to be 350
kilometers over four and a half hours
but we don't say like oh yeah my speed
is whatever kilometers per four and a
half hours we say / one hour right so
how am I going to change this fraction
so that's km/h have you ridden
calculator what your calculators going
to do is it's going to convert that four
and a half hours into just one out right
that's what it what's to do so if you
want to write here and this is sort of
tell you what your calculator is doing
you're dividing the top by four and a
half and your divining the bottom by
four and a half do you see that so now
for elapsed gonna turn into one and this
is going to turn into whatever your
calculator tells me can someone give you
the 177 okay is that exactly rounded I
think thanks Eric repeaters them sure
okay so in fact i guess if we did around
that it would round up portner because
all those sevens it will be so i'm going
to write approximately seventy seven
point eight kilometers per hour like so
okay